So in understanding our customer segments,
it was really helpful to pictures up and as
we build an archetype of who our three potential
customer segments are. The first one we
called Gasol, the next one we called Junior,
and then the third we called Becky. And
we talked about their age, their income,
their demographics. Whether they were
buyer, or whether they were – they were
wearing the jersey as a social statement or
whether they were actually a social sports viewer.
What kind of fan type were they Avid,
In-Season, Casual. What kind of class were
they? Were they upper class and could
they afford anything? Or were they
middleclass or could they barely – they
don’t even have a credit card. What
was their Facebook status, and more
importantly, what kind of rental type
would they like. And it turned out that
it was really helpful to kind of understand
our pricing model and our revenue streams.
So archetypes really helped us understand
our customers, they value prop, the
revenue and some of our pricing tactics.